Das kam jetzt überraschend.
Gerade hatte ich noch beim Max-Planck-Institut
für Radioastronomie in Bonn nachgefargt,
wann endlich das erste Bild des Schwarzen
Lochs Sagittarius A* im Zentrum unserer Galaxie,
der Milchstrasse, veröffentlicht wird.
Frühestens im April wird es soweit sein.
Da gibt es dann von ganz anderer Seite das
erste Bild.
Es ist bei weitem nicht so scharf und aussagekräftig,
aber es ist ziemlich verblüffend und unerwartet.
Ein Schwarzes Loch wie kein anderes?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-
Videos abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s.
Es ist fast unmöglich ein Bild des Schwarzen
Loches im Zentrum der Milchstraße zu machen.
Zwischen der Erde und Sagittarius A* ist ein
Nebel aus heißem Gas.
Er streut das Licht und erschwert die Beobachtung
oder beziehunsgweise macht sie nahezu unmöglich.
Trotzdem ist jetzt erstmal das nahezu Unmögliche
gelungen!
Und gelungen ist das wie beim heiß erwarteten
Bild des Event Horizon Teleskops nur mit der
Zusammenschaltung mehrere Radioteleskope.
In diesem Fall war es das Very Long Baseline
Interferometry" (VLBI) bei dem mehrere Teleskope
auf der Nordhalbkugel zum Beispiel das deutsche
Radioteleskop Effelsberg in der Eifel mit
dem Atacama Large Millimeter Array kurz ALMA
in Chile auf der Südhalbkugel zusammengeschaltet
wurden und so ein riesiges virtuelles Teleskop
entstand.
Es hatte so fast die Größe unserer Erde.
Und jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Nachdem das Forschungsteam die Streuung herausgerechnet
hatte, stieß sie auf ein Leuchten in einem
extrem engen Bereich von nur einem 300millionsten
eines Winkelgrads.
Sara Issaoun vom Forschungsteam: "Das deutet
darauf hin, dass die Radiostrahlung eher von
einer Scheibe mit einfallendem Gas herrührt
als von einem Radiojet" Sie hat die gesammelten
Daten mit zahlreichen Computermodellen durchgerechnet
und komt zu dem Schluss: "Das würde allerdings
Sgr A* zu einer Ausnahme gegenüber allen
anderen Schwarzen Löchern machen, von denen
wir Radiostrahlung empfangen.
Eine Alternative wäre nur, wenn der Jet fast
direkt auf uns zeigt."
Also ein ganz besonderes Schwarzes Loch oder
der schon relativ unwahrscheinliche Fall,
dass ein Jet asu dem Schwarzen Loch direkt
auf uns gerichtet ist.
Heino Falcke, Professor für Astronomie hält
diesen sehr speziellen Fall trotzdem für
eine Möglichkeit: “das bedeutet, dass wir
das Biest unter einem besonderen Blickwinkel
sehen."
Allerdings wäre das schon sehr seltsam.
Das würde bedeuten, dass die Akkretionsscheibe
um das Schwarze Loch im Zentrum unserer Galaxie
exakt um 90 Grad zur Drehungsebene der Galaxie
gekippt ist.
Das wäre ganz anders, als man sich das eigentlich
vorstellen würde.
Demnach kreist um das Schwarze Loch eben eine
Akkretionsscheibe in der Drehungsebene der
Galaxie und die Jets gehen senkrecht nach
oben und unten aus der Drehungsebene aus der
Galaxie heraus.
Eben ganz anders, als jetzt vermutet wird.
Jetzt wird es noch spannender, was das Bild
des Event Horizons Teleskops zeigen wird.
Es macht das Bild bei einer höheren Frequenz
Jetzt ist auf jeden Fall sicher, dass wenn
es einen Schatten des Schwarzen Loches gibt,
er nicht in der Streuung verschwinden wird,
sondern herausgerechnet werden kann.
Noch mehr über das erste Bild im Zentrum
der Milchstrasse gibt es hier - unbedingt
drauflklicken, bei Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft.
Abonniert auch diesen Kanal mit noch ausführlichen
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!